both sides ism
the focus therefore must primarily
be on redressing israeli actions
precisely because this reflects the
unequal relationship of power
whereby israel preeminently determines
outcomes on the ground and denies basic
freedoms to another people
israeli rights cannot be sacrificed but
they cannot come at the expense of
palestinians in need of protection and
the restoration of their rights whether
in gaza the west bank east jerusalem in
refugee camps in the diaspora or when
facing forms of structural
discrimination inside israel
in this context last year's
normalization accords exacerbated this
asymmetry without providing an on-ramp
for peace
mr president these core conceptual
understandings should help guide our
actions
which can in turn create the building
blocks for new thinking and peace they
can also help explain why repeated
attempts at economic peace
at cbms at managing or shrinking the
conflict without addressing occupation
and rights are doomed to continue
failure
as envoy venezuelan said
without the politics
you can't do the rest so how can we do
better
well in a few weeks you will mark the
fifth anniversary of resolution two
three three four
implement two three three four really
implement
that resolution for example calls on all
states to distinguish between the
territory of the state of israel and the
territory occupied since 1967.
so every time israel's illegal
settlements
are allowed to benefit without checks
from trade agreements from bilateral
cooperation and exchanges which israel
has with third parties then 2334 is
violated
one place this differentiation is
happening is in the human rights council
database of companies complicit in doing
business with illegal settlements
achieve a durable ceasefire between
israel and gaza that ends the blockade
of gaza and generates more security for
palestinians and israelis alike talk to
whoever you have to set aside
conditionalities and encourage regional
parties to do likewise
in short this is not about maximum
pressure but it is about using leverage
including the currently neglected
instruments at your disposal
so that palestinian rights are better
protected
to live without the threat of
displacement of arbitrary arrest and
detention with protection for land and
resource rights for freedoms including
those to move and organize
the commitment of the new us
administration to equal measures of
freedom dignity and security for
israelis and palestinians
and the july remarks of chinese foreign
minister wang yi of chinese support for
platforms of informal dialogue and
readiness to offer their own views and
proposals are both welcome and will
hopefully be acted on in meaningful ways
finally mr president
both in this body
and in the respective societies
we can be nurturing and giving breathing
space
to new thinking that is peace oriented
and rights respecting and takes us
beyond the current impasse
that same resolution
five years ago
was passed when a certain joseph r biden
was vice president
that also noted that a one-state reality
was being entrenched
many consider that to be the case
so as this body takes steps to salvage a
two-state outcome
we must also be open to the possibility
that maybe there is no off-the-shelf
solution
at this stage
is there really nothing more to say
about how to address the legitimate
concerns and aspirations of both peoples
the rights of both jews and palestinians
to self-determination without placing
one right on top of the other or pitting
one against the other
for security not to be something that
either israelis or palestinians can have
but a necessity for both
for the rights of palestinian refugees
and the jewish impulse for a refuge of
last resort
to both be
respected to paraphrase the ugandan
academic and author mahmoud
can we think about political identities
and political communities as mutable not
in born
the products of history that have been
created by
and can be dismantled by political
processes in the interest of political
justice
this body
may at some stage
be forced to revisit
its partition vote of 1947 and its
historic endorsement of two states
and if that is not to happen
then far-reaching
and long-delayed thinking and action are
required
that's to be clear
lay outside
of the current collective
comfort zone
i look forward to hearing my friend dr
ashrawi and ambassador manuel and all
the members of this esteemed council
thank you mr president for this
opportunity
i thank mr levy for his briefing
and i'll give the floor to ms hannah
ashrawi
miss ashrae you have the floor
thank you very much
mr president esteemed members of the
security council
i am deeply grateful for the opportunity
to address you today especially thankful
to
kenya to the republic of kenya for this
kind invitation
as you have been hearing for over 70
years the u.n and its various bodies
have been seized of the palestine
question repeatedly reviewing conditions
as we have heard by our esteemed
colleague
thor and his predecessors
adopting resolutions including
234 and dispatching fact-finding
missions to no avail
sadly
this council has been unable to assert
authority allowing this injustice to
become a perpetual tragic human moral
political and legal travesty
so it would be disingenuous of me to
come before you assuming i could inform
you of something that you do not already
know
nevertheless i do appreciate the
opportunity to communicate in a candid
manner not to recite adverse statistics
you have them all not to reiterate the
ongoing pain of the people deprived of
their basic rights
actually including even the right to
speak out
admonished not to whine or complain as a
means of silencing the victim
the tragedies let you know all of this
yet it has had minimal impact if any on
the horrific conditions in occupied
palestine
i imagine it must be disheartening and
frustrating for this distinguished
organization and its members
to find themselves trapped in this cycle
of deliberate disdain and futility
it is therefore imperative that this
council consider where it has gone wrong
and what it can do to correct course and
serve the cause of justice and peace and
particularly in addressing the core
issues and thinking outside the box as
again my colleague daniel has said
undoubtedly the absence of
accountability for israel and of
protection for the palestinian people
has enabled israeli impunity to ride
roughshod over the rights of an entire
nation allowing for the perpetuation of
a permanent settler colonial occupation
mr president
much of the prevailing political
discourse overlooks reality as has been
said and is diverted and subsumed by
chimeras and distractions profited by
israel and its allies under such banners
as economic peace improving the quality
of life normalization
managing the conflict containing the
conflict or even shrinking the conflict
these fallacies must be dismantled
volatile situations of injustice and
oppression do not shrink
they expand and explode with disastrous
consequences
similarly the delusion of imposing calm
under siege and systemic aggression
particularly as in gaza is an oxymoron
or calm or security on the one hand and
occupation or captivity on the other are
antithetical and irreconcilable
likewise the fallacy of confidence
building measures sorry tour but i think
there can be very little confidence
under occupation
the fallacy of confidence-building
measures is misguided since occupation
breeds only contempt distrust resentment
and resistance
the oppressed cannot be brought to trust
or accept handouts from their oppressor
as an alternative to the right to
freedom and justice
the misleading and flawed
both sides argument or both side islam
as daniel said calling for balance in a
flagrantly unbalanced situation is
another attempt at obfuscation and
generating misconceptions
as though both occupying occupied
equal responsibility for this horrific
situation
israel's impunity is further enhanced
using such
excuses as being the so-called
only democracy in the middle east or a
strategic ally
or having shared values
or even for the sake of protecting its
fragile coalition
there has also been tested and at times
overt acceptance of israel's israel's
ideological absolutist arguments
including the invocation of religious
texts as a means to dismiss and supplant
contemporary political and legal
discourse and action
hence the so-called jewish state law
which allocates the right to
self-determination exclusively to jews
in all of historical palestine is
endorsed and normalized
in the meantime
a massive disinformation machine
persists in its racist maligning and
demonizing of the palestinian people
going so far as to label them label us
all as terrorists
or a demographic threat which is a
dehumanizing formula exploited as a way
to deny the right of millions of
palestine refugees to return
such slander has warped political focus
and discourse globally
some states have gone off on a tangent
pursuing palestinian textbooks or
so-called incitement
as though the occupation is not a source
of provocation and incitement
or adopting the ihra definition that
conflates criticism of israel with
anti-semitism
or criminalizing bds for intimidating
and censoring academics and solidarity
activists who stand up for them for
palestinian rights
these distortions ignore the unequal and
unjust laws designed to persecute
palestinians individually and
collectively
it is evidenced in the defamation of our
political prisoners and the targeting of
their families livelihoods as though
israeli military courts courts or prison
systems have anything to do with justice
or legality
you all know that since 1967
over a million palestinians have been
imprisoned and over 75 000 palestinians
have been killed by israel
and yet you label all these people as
terrorists or
not deserving of any kind of rights or
attention
the mindless refrain that israel has the
right to defend itself while the
palestinian people are denied such a
right is perverse
and that the occupiers violence is
justified as self-defense while the
occupied are stigmatized as terrorists
we cannot afford
similarly we cannot afford in all things
we do to disregard the context of
occupation and its systemic aggression
as the framing device for all critical
assessments and actions
everything must be viewed in that
context
excellencies
occupy palestine including jerusalem is
the target of a comprehensive and
pervasive policy of colonization and
erasure we can talk about settlements
forever you have the numbers but it is
nothing but a collective form of
expansion colonization and narration of
displacement and replacement in which
israel is appropriating everything
palestinian
our homes
our land and resources
our cultural and human heritage our
archaeological sites which we have
served safeguarded for centuries
our history
our cuisine the names of our streets and
most egregiously the identity of
jerusalem
as we witness in the ethnic cleansing of
the old city
among others
even our cemeteries have been desecrated
such as the building of the so-called
museum of tolerance on top of human
remains in manila cemetery
and israel continues to stoke the flames
of the holy war with repeated assaults
on our holy sites particularly al-aqsa
mosque
jerusalem is being targeted in a
deliberate campaign of annexation and
distortion and now israel brazenly
declares its intent to complete the
settlement siege of jerusalem and
destruction of the territorial
continuity of the west bank with its
outrageous settlement plans for e1
calandia airport or atarot pisgahzev and
we cannot be distracted by symbolic
gestures that create false impression or
progress we have to look at reality
and claims that the time is not right or
that it is difficult now to work for a
peaceful solution give license to israel
to persist in such perilous policies
and repeating
the verbal commitment to this verbal
commitment to the two-state solution
while one state is allowed to
deliberately destroy the other
rings hollow
mr president
all of this does not preclude our
recognition of our own shortcomings
we do not shirk our responsibility to
speak out against eternal violence human
rights abuses
corruption or other such practices that
are rejected
and presented by our own people it is
our responsibility to carry out
democratic reform and revitalize our
body politic while ending our internal
divisions
this is a palestinian imperative
and we must caution others against
exploiting our shortcomings to justify
israeli crimes or international inaction
or to condition any positive engagement
on the creation of an ideal system of
governance in palestine while we
languish under a lawless system of
israeli control
we ask that you trustees of the
rules-based order uphold your
responsibilities
provide us with protection from
aggression
and empower our people to amplify their
voice both in governance and in
liberation
esteemed members of the council
peace is not achieved by normalizing the
occupation
the palestinian question or rewarding
israel by repositioning it as a regional
superpower
such an approach maintains in place the
causes of regional instability and
security
while enabling israel as a colonial
apartheid state to superimpose greater
israel on all of historic palestine
mr president generation after generation
the people of palestine have remained
committed to the justice of their cause
the integrity of their narrative the
authenticity of their history and
culture and their inviolable right to
live in freedom and dignity
as an equal among nations and in the
fullness of our humanity
it is time to reclaim the narrative of
justice and invoke our collective will
to activate the u.n charter and affirm
the relevance of international law and
as daniel said it is time to think
outside the box and stop doing more of
the same hoping for different results
the time has come for courageous and
determined action not just to undo the
injustice of the past but to chart a
clear and binding course for a peaceful
future of hope and redemption
i thank you for your patience and kind
attention
i thank miss ashwahi
for her briefing
and i'll give the floor to the permanent
observer
of the observer state
of palestine
mr president
we congratulate kenya
on its presidency of the security
council
and thank ambassador masharya kamau
foreign affairs principal secretary of
kenya for presiding over this important
meeting
welcome sir to the security council
we also wish to thank you and special
coordinator thor wensland
for his briefing and to extend a special
word of appreciation to today's
distinguished briefers
my dear sister dr hanan ashrawi
and mr daniel levy
adding the important voice of civil
society to our deliberations on the
situation in the middle east including
the palestine question
mr president
members of the security council
whatever step we take is guided by
the destination we are hoping to reach
the international community identified
this destination a long time ago
and has never deviated from that
determination
this is
what we refer to as the international
consensus
which is based on the two-state solution
on the pre-1967 borders
put it
but it is
patently clear
that this is not the destination that
israel has in mind
this is clear in its insistence on
maintaining its illegal occupation
it is clear in the colonial policies it
pursues on the ground
that aim openly
at making this solution impossible
and it is clear
in the statements of its officials
who negate our right to
self-determination and independence
and denigrate the existence of our
people
given this israeli stance it does not
make much sense
to say
we shall wait until the parties are
ready
and willing
because one party is not only telling
you
that it will not adhere to international
law and the international consensus
but it is also actively violating it
with no regard for your appeals
so how do we hope
to reach the destination of a just and
lasting peace if israel is allowed to
sit alone
behind the stream the steering wheel
determining the course
and our collective faith
it is normal to hope that a certain
sense of
self-preservation and self-interest
would push israel to see that the
project the project it pursues is
self-defeating
but clearly
israelis violation
vision
is guided solely by its colonial
appetite
as proven over and over in its policies
and practices
which breach international law including
this council's resolutions
and are the cause of deep anguish and
hardship for the palestinian people who
have suffered the wrath of its
occupation and the misery of exile for
generations
it has decided to ignore all signals
that demonstrate how unwise
its plans are
after 75 years of these policies aimed
at the
disposition forcible displacement and
denial of rights of our people
and while in 1948
two-thirds of our people were forced to
leave their homeland palestinians are on
the verge of being a majority of the
population that lives between the jordan
river and the sea
but israel believes it can seize our
geography and control our demography
did it manage
to ensure since 1967 the inability of
palestinians to build on over 60 percent
of the west bank and on 87 percent of
east jerusalem
facilitating its plan to unlawfully
annex maximum land with minimum
palestinians
so while palestinians are besieged in
fragmented and even walled enclaves
their land and resources will remain
under israeli control their fundamental
rights will be denied and the dual
system will ensure privileges for one
group and discriminate against another
i know
it sounds familiar
it is called apartheid and
anyone who believes that is a welcomed
prospect is blinded by ideology and a
feeling of supremacy that is destructive
for both those who hold it and those who
suffer from it
israel thinks that the last part of its
plan is palestinian surrender
it calls its palestinian acceptance
of the unlawful reality it has created
to achieve it
it tries to convince palestinians that
they are better off
if they stop struggling
if they accept the premise that
international law does not matter that
palestine is no longer a priority and
that israel will never be held
accountable for its actions
it
wants them
to lose hope so they finally surrender
but what palestinians rely on is not
hope
alone
it is faith
a deep-seated faith that humans cannot
surrender to their chains
and that servitude and captivity of a
nation will never be compatible with the
human condition
your own history
around this table
and in these united nations is a tale
of the rebellion of peoples against
their chains
of valiant struggles for liberation and
justice
so i turn to you
distinguished members of the security
council and as an institution as a whole
you have expressed clear positions
you have been steadfast in your
opposition to illegal unilateral actions
you have given generous assistance and
support to palestinian statehood and
people
you have invested in peace for decades
and decades
of course you could continue intervening
each time we reach a breaking point
when israel decides to formalize its
annexation like you did a year ago
or to deal with the flames generated by
israeli provocations at
sharif
or to stop forcible displacement of
palestinians in sheikh jarrahan silwan
or to broker a ceasefire after israel
killed dozens of palestinian families
like you did in may
or to stop the latest announcement of
settlements that would destroy the
chances of peace as we have witnessed in
recent days
and again
we truly value these efforts
but they only slow down israel on the
destructive path it is embarked on
they do not stop it
we need you to take
hold of the steering wheel
to some
it may seem useless now or difficult
given
competing priorities or requiring too
much political capital for little
progress
but alternative is so dire
that you will eventually need to
intervene
and by then
it will be much more costly and much
more difficult
the security council has
determined clearly the way forward
it has created a mechanism to be an
expression of its will
the quartet
who is better placed to have their hands
on the steering wheel
we need a collective approach that
relies on the positions already adopted
by this council
including resolution 2334
which was mentioned
by the speakers who spoke before me
and on the international community at
large
and that explores the tools available at
the national and international levels in
a genuine spirit of multilateralism
and commitment to the charter's purpose
of the peaceful resolution of conflicts
we need you to accompany the steps you
determined where needed to reach the
destination
with the enforcement of consequences for
those
who refuse to move forward in that path
let us start by putting the brakes on
illegal unilateral measures
let us start by exploring every
available avenue to provide the
palestinian people the protection they
are entitled to
let us mobilize the goodwill
and the means available around the globe
by convening an international conference
under the auspices of the quartet that
would involve the actors who can make a
contribution to peace
let us not think that
momentum appears by magic
it is generated and sustained by our
collective action
thirty years ago
when the madrid peace conference was
held
it was not an expression of the will of
the parties
it was the reflection of the strong will
of the international community
that left the parties with no option but
to show up
no option but to show up
the conference was not successful in
itself
but it generated a dynamic
that allowed peace efforts to reach new
heights and to achieve a breakthrough
if anybody had assessed
the chances of success when shamir was
prime minister
they would have thought that these
efforts were doomed and therefore
useless
the statements and political positions
of israeli prime ministers
by israeli prime ministers cannot be
the decisive factor to determine
if peace efforts have a chance of
success
they are not the only party that decide
and guarantee the chances of success
the only question worth asking is what
incentives does israel have to change
its
does
does israel have to change its behavior
what disincentives does it face
if it persists with the same policies
those who are leading these colonial
policies are hoping to transform the
international community into a bystander
or a silent witness or at worst a
critical commentator
but the international community is an
actor
and a decisive one
and must act as act as such
it is important for the international
community to signal
as soon as possible that it is
determined to ensure
we are on the right track and will not
allow anyone to take the car off the
road
if you are not
the party that can
make determinations and policies related
to the maintenance of international
peace and security
who is the party
that is responsible
for that
the palestinian people will not
disappear mr chairman
and they will continue reinventing their
just struggle until they achieve their
national collective and individual
rights
one way or the other
they will live in freedom and dignity in
their homeland
if we believe the way for this to happen
is through the two-state solution based
on the 1967 borders
action can no longer be delayed
and as it is as the saying goes
action speak
speaks much louder than any articulation
thank you very much mr president
i thank the permanent observer
of the observer state
of palestine for his statement
and i'll give the floor to the
representative of israel
thank you
thank you mr president
30 years ago in october 1991 israeli
prime minister itzhak shamil addressed
the madrid peace conference and declared
we believe the blessing of peace can
turn the middle east into a paradise a
center of cultural scientific medical
and technological creativity it could
put the middle east on the road to a new
era
30 years later we are seeing prime
minister shamir's vision slowly coming
to life
the recent abraham accords and the
long-standing relations between israel
egypt and jordan have put us on the road
to a new era
an era where the middle east will not be
a center of conflict but a center of
creativity and solutions to the world's
most pressing challenges
the potential is particularly clear as
the world prepares for the critical un
conference on climate change in glasgow
israel is a global leader in crucial
areas such as water management
sustainable agriculture and renewable
energy
together with the nations of the abram
accords and all nations which seek peace
we can turn the middle east into a
global hub of climate innovation
for the benefit of our environment our
economies and the future of our children
unfortunately
rather than pushing peace forward the
security council's debates on the
situation in the middle east only seem
to perpetuate the conflict
rather than helping to turn the vision
of peace into a reality
these debates create an alternate and
false reality
these biased debates give the
palestinians the illusion that they will
never be held accountable for their
crimes and that all of their radical
demands could be granted by the
international community
the unbalanced discussions i hope you
felt it only serve to strengthen
palestinian rejectionism of any further
negotiations with israel thereby
maintaining the conflict
today we have heard from the palestinian
ambassador the same lies falsehoods and
distortions which we hear at every
debate on the situation in the middle
east
mr ambassador are you not ashamed to
come before the security council when
your government is paying hundreds of
millions of dollars to terrorists
how can you possibly speak about
aggression when your leaders in schools
glorify the murder of jews and incite
terror
you dare talk about international law
when your courts have just sentenced two
palestinians to 15 years in prison for
the crime of trying to sell land to a
jew
ambassador are you not embarrassed to
speak about human rights while your
police forces are beating to death real
civil society activists such as nizar
bernat
you sit here and talk about the
situation in gaza why don't you tell the
council whose decisions led to cutting
off gaza's electricity in 2017
how can you claim to represent the
palestinian people when 80 percent of
palestinians are fed up with president
abbas
members of the security council
when you allow this body to be turned
again and again into a platform for the
most outrageous anti-israel libels you
are not only stopping the train of peace
from moving forward you are knocking it
off the tracks
as i said these debates reflect an
alternate and false reality detached
from the reality on the ground
an alternate reality in which hundreds
of palestinian terror attacks are not
this council's focus while every israeli
court ruling regarding illegal
palestinian construction becomes the
most critical crisis in the middle east
a false reality in which every
palestinian claim against israel is the
most urgent issue on the agenda while
the terror and destruction of iran and
its proxies throughout the region are
almost an after thought
the latest example of this absurd
approach is the decision to invite as a
representative of civil society an
individual who was a member of the plo
executive committee and who has been a
palestinian politician for decades
what's next
will you invite hassan rouhani and jawad
zarif as representatives of iranian
civil society
mr shrari is not just a lifelong
spokesperson for the palestinian
political leadership she is an opponent
of peace
following the abram accords she
condemned these historic peace
agreements and claimed that the leaders
of the uae and bahrain had been coerced
and cajoled into making a peace making
peace with israel
does the security council really want to
give a platform to an enemy of peace
miftah the organization that ashrawi
founded and led has published
anti-semitic blood libels claiming jews
use christian blood on passover
does the security council really want to
legitimize someone responsible for
spreading gross anti-semitism
if this council wishes to invite members
of civil society why not invite
courageous palestinian and israeli
entrepreneurs who are working together
to create coexistence why not invite
representatives of bodies who are
providing treatment to israeli children
injured and traumatized by hamas's
rocket attacks
and if you have invited miss mizashrawi
why not ask her to explain her criticism
of president abbas for undermining
democracy and establishing an
authoritarian regime
mr president as prime minister shamir
said 30 years ago in madrid israel
strongly desires
peace
it is absolutely critical that this
council sends the clear message that
peace will come when palestinian
authority ceases to pay millions of
dollars in salaries to terrorists and
instead uses those funds to build
medical centers schools and a vibrant
private sector
peace will come when palestinian
children are taught that their national
heroes are scientists inventors and
peace builders rather than terrorists
whose only claim to fame is that they
tried to kill jews
mr president while some members of the
security council remain stuck in the mud
of their anti-israel obsession the real
threat to global security is quickly
advancing
iran continues to progress towards its
goal of becoming a nuclear threshold
state
the murderous ayatollah regime continues
to openly violate its international
commitments in the fields of enrichment
stockpiling uranium uranium metal and
advanced r d while obstructing the iaea
it is using the diplomatic talks to buy
time so that it can enrich uranium to
near weapons grade levels while gaining
nuclear know-how that can never be
reversed
at the same time iran continues to
spread death destruction and instability
throughout the region as it seeks to
advance a shiite hegemony over the
middle east and exports terror around
the world
but you don't have to take it from me
take it from general uralum ali rasheed
a senior commander in iran's armed
forces
in a speech general rashid gave on
september 25th he described the iranian
revolutionary guards grand strategy of
terror
he said i quote
i have assembled for you six armies
outside of iran's territory and i have
created a corridor 1500 kilometers long
and 1 000 kilometers wide all the way to
the shores of the mediterranean sea
one army is in lebanon it is called
hezbollah another army is in palestine
and it is called hamas and the islamic
jihad one army is in syria another army
is in iraq and another army is in yemen
mr president
if the security council doesn't take
strong action against six armies
these six armies will soon be protected
by an iranian nuclear umbrella and the
ayatollah's reign of terror will turn
into a hurricane of violence
let me be clear
israel favors a diplomatic solution a
diplomatic solution that would truly
prevent iran from becoming a nuclear
threshold state
but iran has no intention of negotiating
such a solution
it has no desire for a longer and
stronger agreement
its only desire is to make negotiations
take longer while keeping international
pressure from becoming stronger
the dangers of failing to take action in
the face of iran's flagrant violations
of its commitments cannot be overstated
non-compliance
is a contagious disease especially in
our region
yet seeing as iran poses an existential
threat to israel the state of israel can
never and will never allow iran to
become a nuclear threshold state
we will do whatever is necessary to stop
iran's nuclear drive and counter the
threat from its armies of proxies along
our borders and beyond our borders
mr president president
thirty years after the madrid conference
israel remains committed to peace with
all of our neighbors
the road to peace is clear it requires
standing up to iran the greatest threat
to security in our region
it requires a palestinian leadership
willing to transform its culture of hate
into a culture of peace and it requires
an international community led by the
security council willing to adopt a new
approach based on promoting cooperation
understanding and people-to-people ties
if we take this road we can indeed turn
the middle east into a paradise of
progress prosperity and peace thank you
mr president
i thank the representative of israel for
his statement
i'll now give the floor to the members
of the security council
i give the floor to the representative
of the united states
thank you mr president and thank you
special coordinator winslet for your
briefing and i thank briefers hanan
ashawi and daniel levy for sharing your
views with us today
i welcome the participation of the
observer of the observer state of
palestine mensur and israeli ambassador
adan
before i address what we've just heard i
want to briefly comment on the content
of these monthly
meetings
the monthly agenda calls for a briefing
on the situation in the middle east
including the palestinian question
this council spends a great deal of time
on israeli-palestinian
on the israeli-palestinian conflict
which is both understandable and
consistent with the agenda
but for too often the substance of these
discussions
is centered almost entirely around
criticism of israel and counter-attacks
i sincerely hope that going forward
council members will do their best to
take a more balanced approach
also there are other countries
and situations in the region that
marriage security council attention and
should not be neglected
that said all of us here care sincerely
about providing a better future for both
israelis and palestinians alike
this is a complex crisis with deep
suffering on both sides
along with bringing balance to these
discussions we need to reflect on which
actions truly take us closer to the goal
of peace
the first step toward resolving any
conflict is frank and direct dialogue
so the united states supports the
resumed direct contact between israeli
and palestinian leaders
to that end we also welcome the
re-engagement between israeli and
jordanian leaders as well as the
progress from the abraham accords
i had the opportunity to sit down with
prime minister bennett last month for
productive discussion about the
challenges and opportunities facing
israel here in the u.n system
we've also been engaging with the
palestinian partners and deputy
assistant secretary of state amir
recently traveled to the west bank
to meet with president abbas
gaza continues to have an acute need for
humanitarian relief and recovery
humanitarian actors need regular
predictable and sustained access to gaza
member states should provide financial
as well as material assistance to help
meet the people of gaza's needs
that includes funding unra so the
organization can continue to run schools
and health services that support
palestinian families
the united states provided more than 318
million dollars to unread this year but
it is it still faces a shortfall roughly
of a hundred million dollars we applaud
kuwait's recent contribution of 21.5
million dollars to the agency and we
encourage others to follow kuwait's
example and help ensure the continuation
of vital services for palestinian
refugees
at the same time
we need to see
undertake the necessary reforms to
ensure its financial sustainability and
we will work with unread to strengthen
the agency's accountability transparency
and consistency with humanitarian
principles including neutrality
as the international community moves to
increase its assistance to the people of
gaza we call on hamas to cease its cruel
detention of two israeli civilians
civilians are not pawns
similarly we urge hamas to return the
remains of two israeli soldiers to their
families
i met with leah golden the mother of one
of these soldiers in june and i have to
say i was deeply moved by her account of
the unnecessary suffering caused by this
outrageous act
this is really a matter of basic human
decency and mrs golden's son
remains should be returned to her family
to bring her closure
we are deeply concerned by the violence
perpetrated by israeli settlers in the
west bank against palestinians and their
property
reports of masked men terrorizing a
village in hebron destroying homes and
injuring children on september 28th and
similar acts elsewhere in the west bank
are born
we appreciated the strong and
unequivocal condemnation of this
violence by foreign minister lapid
defense minister gats and others in the
israeli government
we call upon the israeli authorities to
investigate these incidents fully
including the response by israeli
security forces
this kind of violence diminishes the
freedom dignity security and prosperity
of palestinians and israelis alike
it stands in the way of peace
thank you mr president
i thank the representative of the united
states for her statement
and i now give the floor to the
representative of france
president
i thank special coordinator to wenisland
and
mr levy and ms ashrawi for their
briefings
france welcomes the renewed unity of the
council
in its support for the two-state
solution
this is the only solution we have which
meets the legitimate aspirations of
israeli and palestinians people to live
in peace and security
whilst fully upholding the rights of
each
this is why this council has endorsed
the parameters of this solution in
number of resolutions
particularly resolution 2334.
our responsibility today is to strive to
preserve this perspective
we must preserve the possibility of
making peace and ensuring enduring
stability across the region
france
calls upon the parties to abstain from
any unilateral measures we urge israel
to roll back its settlement expansion
plans particularly
in sensitive zones such as
zone e1 and giveth hamatos
these directly jeopardize the viability
and contiguity of a future palestinian
state and they call the two-state
solution into question on the ground as
well as running counter to international
law
france reiterates its concern regarding
the record rise in violence and
demolitions and regarding the eviction
procedures underway in silwan and
sheikshera
our expectations on this front are well
known
all parties must unambiguously reaffirm
their attachments
to a respect for the status quo on the
holy sites in jerusalem any questioning
of this could lead to escalations and a
flare-up in the region once again
president
france welcomes the resumption of
high-level contacts between israel and
the palestinian authority which opened
the way to a new dynamic
to greater cooperation in all areas and
this is in everyone's interests and
first and foremost
those of the people more must be done to
preserve the ceasefire in gaza i welcome
the action of egypt after the welcome
relaxing of some restrictions upon gaza
by israel it is essential that the items
necessary for reconstruction and
humanitarian personnel can get into gaza
international law must be respected
complementary measures
for the economic recovery will be
necessary we condemn any attack
targeting israeli territory
greater cooperation on the economic
front is necessary to stabilize the
situation in the west bank
we hope that the ministerial meeting of
the ad hoc liaison committee in november
will be the opportunity to make progress
including in tax matters
my final point is on the respect for the
rule of law and the buttressing of
palestinian democratic institutions
we recall
our expectations with regard to the
palestinian authority with regard to
upholding human rights and fundamental
freedoms which are well known
in particular full light must be shared
on the killing of nizar bannet
france is committed to accompanying all
initiatives contributing to
re-establishing dialogue between
re-establishing dialogue we are striving
towards this end alongside our
german egyptian or jordanian partners i
seize this opportunity to restate our
support for the work of the special
coordinator towards venice land
france
will play an active part in the donor
conference for unrwa in november
onwards action is essential for the
stability of the region and to meet the
needs of palestinian refugees thank you
very much
i thank the representative of france for
his statement
and i now gave the representative of
saint vincent and the grenadines
thank you mr president let me begin by
also thanking special coordinator to
awarenessland
mr daniel
levy
president of the u.s middle east project
and ms hannah as
as
raoui
political and
civil society leader for their briefings
and i thank our colleague
representatives of the state of
palestine
and israel for their statements
for decades the international community
has been witness
to the israeli occupation of palestine
every month we come to the council and
state our positions in line with
international law
and u.n resolutions
but this does not seem to move the
needle
our words do not stop the erosion of
palestinian statehood
the killing of palestinian children
nor the attempted erasure of a people
and their homes
cynically and paradoxically
such observations have in the not too
distant past spawned
arguments that we must do away
with international law and the two-state
solution
such an approach rocks the foundation of
our rules-based international order
the refusal of israel to come to terms
with the requisite of an independent
palestine
and a secure israel
remains our biggest hurdle
in these new perilous times which
humanity faces we must do better
we must
as mr
levy suggests
disengage from autopilot
and implement resolution 23 34
in the interest of a political solution
and political justice
mr president
recent developments with respect to
israeli settlements are of particular
concern
the recent announcement of approvals for
advancing the construction of thousands
of homes in e1 is a flagrant violation
of international law
and further undermines the peace process
and two-state solution
we renew our call on the israeli
authorities to urgently reverse these
latest decisions
as a matter of urgency
yet again saint vincent and the
grenadines denounces the continuing and
increasing demolition and confiscation
of palestinian houses and structures in
the occupied palestinian territory
including east jerusalem
the situation in sheikh jara
east jerusalem which remains under
threat of forced eviction of palestinian
families from their homes is also
troubling
we call on israel to immediately halt
all forced evictions and to cease
its systematic policy
of settlement expansion demolition
of palestinian structures and
obstructing palestinian development
we also deeply we are also deeply
concerned
about allegations of the use of
excessive force by israeli security
forces against palestinian civilians
this includes the killing and wounding
of palestinian civilians including
children
therefore we reiterate our call on
israel
to observe international humanitarian
law as set out in the geneva conventions
of 1949
turning to the recent developments
surrounding
al-aqsa
we call on
all to respect the historic and legal
status quo at this holy site
in the interest of peace and stability
while noting that
the israeli authorities have eased some
of the restrictions in gaza
much more needs to be done to prevent an
even more grim future for palestinians
continued humanitarian access and
funding services to the palestinian
population in gaza remain critical
we call attention once more to the
israeli illegal blockade of the gaza
strip
the blockade must end to facilitate
rapid and unimpeded passage of
humanitarian relief for palestinians in
need and reconstruction
of gaza moreover we call on the
international community to make tangible
investment
to resolve the critical funding
shortfalls
for the reconstruction efforts in gaza
and programmes run by the united nations
relief and works agency for palestinian
refugees in the near east
before closing mr president
my delegation welcomes the united states
plans
for the re-establishment of a u.s
consulate in jerusalem saint vincent and
the grenadines reminds once again that
there is no substitute for a two-state
solution between israelis and
palestinians
time is running out on us
we need to work collectively to promote
genuine dialogue between the parties
only through dialogue and negotiations
can there be lasting peace in israel and
palestine
and the wider
middle east thank you mr president
i thank the representative of saint
vincent and the grenadines for her
statement
and i now give the floor to the
representative of ireland
thank you very much mr president and
it's a privilege to see you in the chair
back amongst us today
and as always a sincere thanks to thor
for his comprehensive briefing this
morning i'd like to welcome ambassadors
mansur and er erdan with us
today um i want to say a very special
thanks to hanan ashrawi um
who has for so long been such really an
eloquent and powerful voice for the
palestinian people and i want to
recognize in particular your work in
recent years working as a strong
advocate for a younger generation of
palestinian women and men much much
appreciated and thank you daniel
for what was really a very
valuable of course contribution but also
very thought-provoking it was really
good to hear from you today and for your
long-standing contributions
to israeli-palestinian discussions
mr president we're
deeply concerned about the briefing we
had from toward this morning and what we
know about the rise in violence across
the west bank particularly the increase
in settler violence and use of live fire
by israeli forces
we call on israel to hold those
responsible accountable
to end the culture of impunity around
such ancient incidents of violence and
to ensure that any response by security
forces is proportional and in compliance
with international law
ireland condemns all acts of violence
including rocket attacks from gaza which
fuel tensions and put civilian lives at
risk
once again i repeat ireland's call on
israel to halt all illegal settlement
activity including in east jerusalem and
in the e-1 area as well as demolitions
evictions and seizures of
palestinian-owned structures
israel should provide permits for legal
construction and development of
palestinian communities
ireland remains firmly committed to a
negotiated two-state solution which
provides a viable basis for a resolution
of the israel-palestine conflict we
condemn
all acts that threaten to erode this
prospect
we call for the status quo at the holy
sites in jerusalem to be upheld in both
word and practice
recognizing the special role of jordan
mr president last month during ireland's
security council presidency two young
women addressed this same debate um ms
mai farsak underscored the terrible
impact of illegal settlements on
palestinian women and girls
miss meredith rothbart
illustrated for us clearly the essential
role and the constructive role of civil
society and local peace building
clearly we saw through them the
occupation has a disproportionate impact
on women and girls
ireland commends civil society and the
occupied palestinian territories and in
israel for their efforts to develop an
approach of community-based women's
empowerment
through those young women last month we
saw that they have the capacity to shape
a more hopeful future for their
societies
we believe it's imperative that this
council the parties to the conflict and
the international community listen to
their voices
we strongly condemn recent targeting of
palestinian activists and civil society
organizations
ireland calls on all duty bearers israel
and palestinians alike israeli and
palestinians alike to protect and uphold
the rights of civil society and human
rights defenders
mr president ireland condemns the vital
work of unra which is of critical
importance to millions of palestine
refugees in the occupied territory
and across the region and once again
appeals to donors including our golf
partners to enhance support for unra
mr president despite some recent welcome
steps we remain deeply concerned about
access into gaza
and
obstacles to reconstruction efforts
five months after the end of the
conflict
as noted in the rapid damage and needs
assessment there are significant mental
health consequences faced by gazans from
prolonged exposure to violence loss of
family and loved ones and the
frustrations of lack of control from
worsening poverty unemployment and
insecurity in the gaza strip
we renew our call on israel to end the
blockade of gaza
mr president we welcome the announcement
by the palestinian electoral commission
that municipal elections will be held in
december ireland reiterates its belief
that legislative palestinian elections
across all of the occupied territory
with the full participation of women are
necessary to give a democratic voice to
all palestinians to help progress toward
intra-palestinian reconciliation
and renewal of the legitimacy of
national institutions
finally mr president
ireland reiterates our call on the
middle east quartet to enhance their
efforts to work towards the resumption
of a political process
we welcome ministerial level contacts
between the israeli government and the
palestinian authority which have taken
place in recent weeks
as we approach the 30th anniversary of
the madrid conference it's imperative
that this council
partners in the region and the wider
international community remain engaged
in working for a solution to the
israel-palestinian conflict
there can be no doubt that we need to
rekindle the hope that took hold in
madrid
we need to work to build confidence to
enable a political path for an end to
occupation that began in 1967 so that
palestinian rights as well as those of
israelis can be guaranteed
ireland stands ready able through this
council and nationally to assist in
whatever way we can thank you mr
president
i thank the representative of ireland
for her statement
and i now give the floor to the
representative of estonia
thank you mr president
i thank special coordinator venezuelan
for his briefing
and i also thank mr levy and ms ashravi
for their insightful statements
estonia remains committed to finding a
long-lasting solution to the
israeli-palestinian conflict
based on the two-state solution
international law and relevant security
council resolutions
we continue to support all efforts to
create favorable conditions for the
resumption of direct meaningful
negotiations on all final status issues
we welcome the recent engagement between
the israeli and palestinian leaders and
encourage them to expand this dialogue
further
we also urge the parties to engage in
more practical cooperation including in
economic financial and other areas
which would serve as confidence-building
measures and would be in the interest of
the people of both sides
regarding gaza
it is vital to continue stabilizing the
fragile situation
we support the international and
regional efforts aimed at reducing
tensions and holding the ceasefire in
gaza
we call upon hamas and other terrorist
organizations to refrain from firing
rockets and incendiary devices into
israel and urge israel to use its right
to defend itself proportionally
protecting the civilian population
it is also essential that international
and regional efforts for reconstruction
continue
with the aim of improving the dire
humanitarian and socio-economic
situation on the strip
in this context
we welcome the recent proposals to
advance economy
and improve the socio-economic situation
of the palestinians
turning to the west bank
we are worried about continued incidents
of violence including the clashes
between the palestinians and the israeli
security forces
we call on all parties to refrain from
violence incitement and acts of
provocation
the demolitions and evictions of
palestinian property by israel
is worrying
we call upon israel to refrain from
these activities as well as from
advancing any settlement plans as such
acts are contrary to international law
we also reiterate
that the status quo of the holy sites
must be fully respected
finally i would like to stress the
important role of unra
in providing help to the palestinian
refugees and stabilizing the region
including through humanitarian response
and reconstruction in gaza
the upcoming conference hosted by sweden
and jordan
is an important opportunity to find ways
towards more sustainable funding of the
agency thank you mr president
i thank the representative of estonia
for his statement
and i now give the floor to the
representative of norway
thank you president
and
also thank you to special coordinator
venezuelan for your very thorough
although slightly concerning briefing
today
and thank you also to daniel levy and
hananas ravi for your very valuable
contributions
let me begin by reiterating norway's
enduring commitment to a broad political
solution to the israeli-palestinian
conflict
this conflict is often overshadowed by
seemingly more urgent crisis on the
council's agenda yet it is critical that
we keep focus on the need to address the
underlying issues issues here as well
we reaffirm our support for a negotiated
tuesday solution
on the basis of the 67 lines relevant
security council resolutions including
international law and internationally
agreed parameters where israel
israelis and palestinians can live side
by side in peace and with insecure and
recognized borders
president the current relative calming
gaza as well as the recent increase in
imports and number of work permits
issued is a positive development the
distribution of cash assistance to tens
of thousands of vulnerable families has
also been successful
however as the special coordinator has
highlighted this situation is not
sustainable the closure of gaza must be
lifted
and to improve the lives of palestinians
living in gaza we must spur economic
growth
by allowing many more gazans to seek
work in israel and in the west bank
generating good jobs in gaza itself and
easing imports and export restrictions
we call on all actors to contribute to
keeping the calm and avoiding further
hostilities and we support all efforts
to secure a long-term and stable
ceasefire
calm is a prerequisite for true progress
in rebuilding gaza better
norway welcomes the signal from the
israeli government that it will support
improving living conditions in gaza
and the palestinian authority will
remain our partner for development
effort in palestine including in gaza
president we are deeply concerned about
israeli plans to implement the e-1
settlement plan
such settlements would cut off east
jerusalem from the rest of the west bank
and undermine the viability of a
continuous palestinian state
israeli settlement on occupied
territories constitute a violation of
international law and we urge israel to
halt settlement activities house
demolition and evictions
these actions have not only inflamed the
recent escalation around gaza they go
against international efforts to
stabilize the situation and solve the
conflict
we are also deeply worried about the
increased violence including settler
violence in the west bank
we remind israel of its responsibility
to protect civilians especially children
and call on israel to stop the use of
live ammunition against palestinian
protesters
we call ourselves the pa to uphold the
human rights and to refrain from
limiting the space of civil society
president norway welcomes the renewed
high-level dialogue between israel and
the palestinian authority
and we were encouraged to hear from to
veniceland that there have also been
recent contexts in the quartet
we stand ready to assist in further
strengthening dialogue
norway will host an hlc meeting on the
16th and 17th november in oslo to
address the deteriorating physical
situation of the pa and consider how to
strengthen the authority
the meeting will also provide an
opportunity for the parties the donors
and development partners to agree on
concrete steps forward on both on the
economic and the political aspect of
palestinian state building
the two-state solution is the only
solution that will ensure long-term
stability which will benefit not only
israelis and palestinians but the region
as a whole thank you
i thank the representative of norway for
her statement
and i now give the floor to the
representative of mexico
thank you very much president
i think
special coordinator when island
ms ashrawi and mr levy
for their valuable
briefings
we also welcome the delegations of
israel and palestine to this council
meeting
president we have once again heard
accounts of the
prevailing tension and violence within
the region
the conflict persists
violations of human rights continue
and there is no progress towards the
goal
which would allow for a solution which
many of us
had hoped and believed could be a
definitive solution the creation of a
palestinian state which is sovereign and
independent politically and economically
viable which lives in peace with israel
within safe internationally recognized
borders
in view of this
and in view of what we have heard this
morning
i will focus on three points
firstly settlements and violence
then the stake is status quo in
jerusalem
and
gaza and intra-palestinian
reconciliation
firstly
settlements and violence the
construction and spend expansion of
israeli settlements in occupied
palestinian territory
runs counter to international law
moreover it is an obstacle for the
implementation of any of the
perspectives for peace
above and beyond figures which are
significant
this year alone
682 structures have been demolished
including some financed by the
international community
and others which are necessary for
health and drinking water services
the construction of new housing units
in settlements such as give out hamatos
attarot
and pisgatsev
the geographical continuity of the
palestinian state
therefore the construction of units in
this context must cease as must the
transfer of settlers the demolition of
homes and the displacement of civilians
measures must be promoted to reverse the
negative trends on the ground
in line with resolution 23 34.
secondly
we note with concern the increasing
tension
in the old city of jerusalem
which is the result of actions and words
favorable to a change in the status quo
we note the fact that the israeli
authorization for non-muslims to enter
and pray at the holy esplanade
was overturned
by the competent authorities
in line with the resolutions of this
council mexico urges that parties
refrain from measures which alter the
status and the geographical demographic
and historic character of jerusalem
thirdly
mexico
urges the palestinian authority to
continue organizing municipal elections
and
once again to convene parliamentary and
presidential elections
we wish to
underscore the importance of
guaranteeing
full
equal and substantive participation by
women and young people in the political
and civil life of palestine
we also welcome the continued mediation
efforts by egypt
towards intra-palestinian reconciliation
president cooperation between israel and
the palestinian authority in civil and
security matters
and in particular the high-level
contacts being sought
are all encouraging signs and welcome
signs
we hope that these continue and expand
towards a political understanding for
the peace negotiations
we commend the effort to reactivate the
palestinian economy
in particular those efforts which seek
to boost the economy in gaza
and we reiterate the need to lift the
israeli blockade and to guarantee
consistent regular
entry of commodities and reconstruction
materials into the strip
by way of conclusion the question of
palestine is probably one of the most
long-standing items on the council's
agenda
regrettably after seven decades
we are continuing with the same cycle of
administering the conflict
we call for the start of direct
negotiations without delay and without
preconditions with the support of the
international community
and in particular the middle east
peace quartet
we truly believe
that this is the path to follow i thank
you president
i thank the representative of mexico for
his statement and i now give the flow to
the representative of
china thank you mr president mr
president
i welcome
mr kamau to the council to preside over
today's meeting
and thank the special coordinator
winslet for his briefing and also thank
miss ashwari and mr levy for their
statements
china is deeply concerned of the
humanitarian situation in the occupied
territory of palestine
nearly five months after the gaza
conflict the security and humanitarian
situation in the occupied palestinian
territory remains green
in the gaza strip the conflict in may
damaged a large number of public
facilities and civilian houses
worsening the already severe economic
and humanitarian situation
of the 110 000 displaced people in gaza
8250 still have not yet returned to
their homes
more delay in the recovery and
reconstruction of gaza will cause
greater suffering of the people already
affected by the conflict
china appreciates the efforts aimed at
alleviating the plight of the local
population such as the issuance of cash
assistance by qatar and the u.n and the
work done by angra in spite of
difficulties
we call
for the early reconstruction of gaza to
restore the normal life of the people
and the international community should
increase its support for this
reconstruction
israel should open more relevant ports
in gaza
to clear the obstacles for the entry of
humanitarian and reconstruction
materials into gaza
china strongly called for the easing of
tension
in the west bank
israelis military and police operations
continue to cause palestinian casualties
aggravate the conflicts between the two
sides and escalate tension
the violence by israeli settlers has
intensified exemplified by the attack on
september 28th which injures several
palestinians
including a
three-year-old child in his sleep
as the special coordinator wenislan has
repeatedly emphasized
israel as the occupying power must
fulfill its obligations under the
international humanitarian law by
guaranteeing the safety of the people in
the occupied territory
thoroughly investigating the attacks and
bringing those responsible to justice
china urges israel to stop its actions
that undermines the prospects of the
two-state solutions such as expansion of
settlements
recently israel has approved to build a
new settlement in kiva hamatos in
jerusalem
and
palestinian residents in communities
such as xi'jala are still at risk of
being evicted
the construction of settlements violates
international law and undermines the
prospects of the two-state solution
israel must abide by the relevant u.n
resolutions stop expanding settlements
stop demolishing palestinian houses
and stop evicting palestinian people
the historically established status quo
of jerusalem as a religious holy site
should be maintained and respected
mr president
the fundamental way to solve the
palestinian issue lies in the
implementation of the two-state solution
two weeks ago the permanent observer of
palestine stated in a letter to the
president of the security council that
the international community should not
replace the just settlement of the
palestinian issue with crisis management
and control
china fully agrees with this
only by realizing the two-state solution
and restoring the legitimate rights of
the palestinian people can the cycle of
violence be broken
and pakistan and israel live side by
side
and coexist in peace
we hope
that palestine and israel will take the
recent high-level context as an
opportunity to continue to build
momentum gradually re-establish mutual
trust and resume equal dialogue at an
early date
we support egypt and other countries in
the region in playing an important role
to promote reconciliation among
palestinians and call for strengthening
the authority of the palestinian
national authority and empowering it to
exercise sovereignty functions in
security finance and other fields
we urge countries with important
influence
to uphold an objective and fair position
avoid partiality and double standards on
the issue of palestine
the security council bears the primary
responsibility for maintaining
international peace and security and
must take effective actions to resolve
the palestinian issue
we reaffirm our readiness to host direct
negotiation between palestine and israel
in china
and calls for
the holding of an international peace
conference led by the un with the
participation of permanent members of
the security council and various
stakeholders in the middle east peace
process
mr president china has always attached
great importance to the humanitarian
situation in pakistan and has taken
concrete actions to support the
palestinian people in their fight
against the pandemic on many occasions
china has sent humanitarian assistance
such as emergency cash assistance
anti-pandemic supplies and vaccines to
palestine china will donate an
additional 1 million doses of vaccines
and will join forces with egypt to send
500 000 doses of vaccines to people in
the gaza strip
we will also provide 200 000 doses of
vaccines to angra
as a sincere friend of pakistan china
supports the just cause of palestine in
pursuing its national rights and
establishment of a fully sovereign and
independent pakistan state based on the
1967 borders with east jerusalem as its
capital
we will continue to work with the
international community to promote an
early comprehensive reasonable and just
settlement of the palestinian issue
i thank you mr president
i thank the representative of china for
his statement and i now give the floor
to the representative of niger
thank you mr president
i wish to
thank
mr levy and mr venislain for their
briefings one month ago the announcement
of a plan to uh for the reconstruction
of gaza the meeting in ramallah between
the palestinian president and the
israeli defense minister as well as the
visit in egypt of the israeli prime
minister
were
welcomed by us
as we called for
the
glimmers of hope to be built upon to
ease tensions between israel and
palestine
we are mindful of the fragility of the
restored calm since the ceasefire of
last may we
called for the
need to reinforce
on both sides measures to contribute to
greater calm to ease tensions and to
rebuild trust between the israeli and
palestinian people to set the stage for
resumption of the peace process
however
in the light of the circumstances that
have been observed in the region
for some time now the prospect of
peaceful coexistence of the two peoples
and the prospect of a restoration of
peace continue to be undermined
resulting in a perpetually looming
specter of instability and violence the
resurgence of attacks and persecution
perpetrated by israeli settlers
targeting palestinians
including farmers and even school
children the ongoing demolition of
palestinian structures including
agricultural sites the confiscation of
palestinian private property property
the approval by israeli authorities of a
construction plan
of a number of housing units
in palestinian areas located in
jerusalem
as well as the desecration of muslim
cemeteries and violations targeting
islam holy sites specifically the
al-aqsa mass mosque
all constitute grave acts which are
reprehensible they need to end
turning to the recent
attacks targeting a muslim sanctuaries i
wish to emphasize that these are
shocking and appalling to muslims in
palestine and the rest of the world
these practices
merely foment hatred fanaticism
radicalization and violence thereby
inevitably making
the solution to an already difficult
situation all the more difficult and
obstructing the path towards
a restoration of peace and peaceful
co-existence between the palestinian and
israeli people for this reason we
vehemently condemn
these heinous unacceptable actions
targeting muslim holy sites we invite
israel to spare no effort to end this we
wish to recall that it is incumbent upon
the israeli authorities to protect
worshipers ensure respect for holy sites
and respect for the historic and legal
status of jerusalem which is a holy city
for the three monotheistic religions
my country continues to believe that in
order to achieve peace which we have
sought for more than 70 years in the
middle east the palestinian cause cannot
endlessly be circumvented the flagrant
disregard of israel
for international law and u.n
resolutions cannot go on at infinitum
the palestinian cause
continues to loom large
and there's a persistent call of the
palestinian people to exercise
self-determination these conditions for
the peace which we have championed for
the region
roots is
rooted in an end to the frenzied
settlement activity which has been
carried out by israel for a number of
decades in the palestinian entire
occupied territories and there's a a
need for a resumption of direct talks
between israelis and palestinians with a
view to achieving the soul-worthy
solution to their dispute that of the
creation of a palestinian a viable
palestinian state
within the 1967 borders living side by
side in peace with israel this solution
needs to be safeguarded at all costs
the council through its obligations
should ensure compliance with
resolutions they cannot be optional they
need to be imperative respect for these
resolutions is a guarantor for peace and
security for all parties and for all
members who have embraced the ideals of
the united nations charter likewise
there is an important need for the
international community the quartet
members of the council as well as
regional actors with influence to bear
on the parties to continue to
bring the necessary pressure to bear to
avert
further escalation and to strive for
achievement of the peace process for a
peaceful solution to conclude we wish to
voice our concern at the humanitarian
situation in the occupied palestinian
lands
we are concerned by the covet 19
pandemic in its fallout which has been
exacerbated by the fragility of the
health system extreme poverty food
insecurity among other factors in gaza
the ongoing illegal blockade by israel
has been ongoing for nearly 13 years
there is overpopulation
there is fallout from the recent israeli
air strikes in the enclave and there are
consequences from the financial deficit
that anwar has been experiencing these
continue to imperil
thousands of palestinians most of whom
are women and children for this reason
we urge the international community to
be more compassionate to be more
generous vis-a-vis this weary population
by supporting financing for the gaza
reconstruction plan as well as for the
vital pam of uh programs which are vital
for thousands of families of programs
provided by unrwa we invite israel as
the occupying power to
honor its responsibility under
international humanitarian law to
provide for the well-being and survival
of the population under its control
thank you
i thank the representative of niger for
his statement
and i now give the representative of the
united kingdom
thank you mr president and may i welcome
you back to new york
thank you also to the special
coordinator for your briefing
and to our two civil society briefers mr
daniel levy and dr hanan ashrawi for
their thought-provoking contributions
mr president
i'd like to start by welcoming the
increased engagement by between the
government of israel and the palestinian
authority over recent months
we are confident this dialogue will
continue
and it is our hope that it will deliver
tangible results
to tackle immediate and long-term
threats to peace and stability
the parties have our full support in
this
the united kingdom also welcomes the
increased calm in gaza
and recent steps taken by israel
to reduce constraints on access for
goods and people into and out of the
strip
we now ask israel to set out a full and
transparent plan to improve movement and
access in gaza
in line with international humanitarian
law
to allow for reconstruction and
development to advance
a number of positive signals
notwithstanding
we continue to see negative trends in
the west bank
including east jerusalem
as we've heard
rates of demolitions and evictions of
palestinians from their homes
have continued to rise
and this year
may see the worst rate of demolitions in
five years
we urge the government of israel to
ensure
that palestinian families living in the
occupied territories can remain safely
in their homes
violence in the west bank including
settler attacks against palestinian
people and property
is now on the rise
the shocking attack on the palestinian
village of umufakara in the south hebron
hills on the 28th of september
resulted in a three-year-old palestinian
child
being hospitalized
we call on israel to provide the
appropriate protection to the
palestinian civilian population
to ensure all such incidents are
investigated thoroughly
and for those responsible to be brought
to justice
we welcome the government of israel's
commitment to addressing settler
violence
and foreign minister lapid's
condemnation
of the um
attack
we're also concerned about the israeli
security forces use of excessive force
we continue to urge israel
to uphold the principles of necessity
and proportionality
when defending its legitimate security
interests
the palestinian authorities dire fiscal
situation carries the risk that it is
unable to pay salaries or its suppliers
in full
from next month onwards
rapid action is needed to improve the
situation
the uk will continue to work with the
palestinian authority
to help it implement necessary reforms
and we urge our international partners
to do the same
lastly mr president
as we celebrated the international day
of the girl child last week
we were reminded of the impressive
educational attainment rates for girls
across the occupied palestinian
territories
we must celebrate this success
and ensure that the vital provision of
education
including to girls is protected from the
threat of instability
in conclusion
the lack of progress
in the middle east peace process
continues to impact negatively the lives
of everyday israelis and palestinians
and the ongoing conflict
is in need
of a just and lasting resolution
we continue to urge all parties to renew
their commitment to peace building
and to work to deliver it
the uk continues to believe that a
two-state solution offers the only
meaningful prospect for durable peace
and i thank you mr president
i thank the representative of the united
kingdom for her statement
and i now give the floor to the
representative of tunisia
thank you mr president at the outset i
would like to welcome your presidency of
this session and i would like to thank
the un special coordinator for the
middle east priests process mr
torwensland for his detailed briefing
we highly appreciate the efforts of the
u.n secretary general and the united
nations coordinator for the peace
process the commissioner general of the
underwent all u.n staff
in the occupied territories for their
attempts at alleviating the suffering of
the palestinian people and promoting
chances for peace in the middle east
we would also like to commend the role
of civil society in supporting these
efforts and thank dr hanan ashrawi and
mr daniel levy for their briefings mr
president
in light of the decades-long historical
injustice against the palestinian people
and the continued
systematic violation
of their most basic legitimate rights by
the occupying power the international
community has been demanding a just
comprehensive and lasting solution to
the palestinian-israeli conflict that
would put an end to the occupation and
enable the palestinian people to
establish an independent sovereign and
contiguous state along the 1967 borders
with east jerusalem as its capital
despite this
international support to the legitimate
demands of the palestinian people and
the two-state solution
the occupying power continues to flout
international law and security council
resolutions most recently resolution 23
by imposing a de facto policy on the
ground it is furthering its expansionist
settlement plans
forcibly displacing palestinians
and confiscating their homes and lands
it is continuing its attempts to alter
the historical demographic and legal
status of al-quds or jerusalem in
addition to other serious violations
and the repeated attacks against
palestinians by settlers in
west in the west bank in the absence of
any accountability in this context
tunisia reiterates its categorical
rejection of attempts to change the
status quo in jerusalem's holy sites and
renews its support for the historical
hashemite guardianship of those holy
sites
considering the violence and attacks
against the palestinian civilian
population including women and children
tunisia also calls for their protection
pursuant to international law
mr president
the continuation of the current
situation in the occupy territories
would only lead to further escalation
especially in the absence of any real
prospects for conflict settlement based
on resolutions of international
legitimacy and agreed upon terms of
reference this has only led to greater
feelings of injustice despair and
hopelessness among palestinians
especially youth
proceeding from its responsibility to
maintain international peace and
security the security council is
required to do what is needed to ensure
the implementation of its resolutions on
the palestinian-israeli conflict
in particular
ending settlement activities and
endeavoring to break the deadlock in the
middle east peace process
in line with the prerogatives granted by
the security council to the
international middle east quartet
we look forward to their intensifying
effort to help resume negotiations as
soon as possible
in this regard we express our support to
the proposal of holding an international
peace conference by the quartet mr
president
in the face of the deteriorating
humanitarian situation in the gaza strip
particularly following the recent
military aggression the continued
blockade for more than 14 years
and the repercussions of covered 19
pandemic we stress the importance of
facilitating humanitarian access
lifting restrictions on the freedom of
movement and trade and refraining from
obstructing reconstruction effort
we also call upon international donors
to increase the level of humanitarian
assistance and response in the occupied
palestinian territories and to support
relevant un efforts
in this vein we underline the pressing
need to provide additional funding to
anwa
to
address its budget deficit
we also call for predictable and
sustainable funding
to the agency's budget we look forward
to the pledging conference
to be organized by jordan and sweden
jointly in support of anwar in
conclusion we reiterate that achieving
security and stability in the middle
east region inevitably requires a just
comprehensive and lasting solution to
the arab-israeli conflict in accordance
with international law resolutions of
international legitimacy and the arab
peace initiative tunisia will remain
steadfast in its support for just causes
foreign being the palestinian question
until the palestinian people regain
their full legitimate rights which will
not fall under the statute of
limitations thank you mr president
i thank the representative of tunisia
for his statement
and i now give the floor to the
representative of india thank you
thank you mr president
i welcome your presiding over today's
meeting
i thank special coordinator thor
venislain for his briefing
i also thank miss hanan ashrawi
and mr daniel levy for their insights
and i welcome the participation of the
ambassador of israel and the ambassador
of palestine in our meeting
india's position on the palestinian
issue is
the palestine issue is consistent and
well known
we firmly believe that only the
establishment of a sovereign viable and
independent state of palestine
within recognized and mutually agreed
borders living side by side with israel
and peace and security
taking into consideration the legitimate
security concerns of israel can deliver
a durable and lasting solution to the
conflict
i reiterate india's long-standing
position that the palestine issue be
resolved through a peacefully negotiated
settlement that promotes a two-state
solution
the maintenance of peace and stability
is a prerequisite for that to go forward
mr president consolidating the ceasefire
in gaza and expediting its
reconstruction should continue to remain
a priority of the u.n and the
international community
we call on all parties to the conflict
to respect the cease-fire
continue their cooperation and
coordination with the un and take
concrete steps that would improve the
economic and humanitarian situation of
the civilians in gaza
i also reiterate the urgent need to
address the underlying causes that have
resulted in the deterioration of the
situation in gaza
i reaffirm india's call for regular and
predictable transfer of aid and other
essential items to gaza to ease the
humanitarian situation and facilitate
early reconstruction as well as for
appropriate use of such aid
it is also important that the
international donor community supports
the reconstruction of gaza strip through
the palestinian authority
we also encourage parties to remain
engaged on the prisoner exchange
discussions and work towards a positive
outcome this being a humanitarian
imperative
we appreciate the role of egypt in
facilitating these talks
we condem all acts of violence against
civilians as well as all acts of
provocation incitement and destruction
we call for desisting from provocative
action and inflammatory rhetoric in the
interest of peace and stability
we underscore the need to respect and
maintain the historic status quo in the
holy city
holy sites of jerusalem
we are concerned by palestinian
authorities
fiscal situation which has been further
exacerbated by the kovid-19 pandemic
international community needs to support
the palestinian socio-economic recovery
with the focus on social protection in
line with the priorities of the
palestinian authority
we appreciate the recent announcements
to improve the economic and
administrative relationships between
israel and the palestinian authority and
these announcements have to be
translated into action
underwater plays an important role in
providing humanitarian and development
assistance
india has continued to support the
agency's core budget through annual
voluntary contributions
india has been consistently supporting
palestinian nation-building efforts
under the india-palestine development
partnership in addition to our ongoing
projects in health education technology
sectors we are also implementing quick
impact projects which would benefit the
local communities
these programs have continued despite
the covet 19 pandemic
mr president
we also call upon the international
community the middle east quartet in
particular
to take concrete steps towards resuming
and facilitating peace negotiations in
this regard we welcome the continued
high-level exchanges between the israel
government and the palestinian authority
these exchanges would help build
confidence between the parties and
create a favorable environment for
resumption of peace negotiations
such measures should run parallel to
efforts to restart the direct
negotiations which remain the best
pathway to reach the two-state solution
i thank you
i thank the representative of india for
his statement and i now give the floor
to the representative of the russian
federation
especially
thank you mr president
we wish to thank the special coordinator
for verizon for the briefing bulletin
attentively to the representative of
civil society
mr daniel levy and madam hanan ashrawi
we welcome your personal participation
in this meeting mr kamal the achievement
of a lasting peace and security in the
middle east and north africa remains
among the top priorities on the agenda
of the united nations security council
we are obliged to note with regret that
progress in resolving the myriad
regional crises has not yet been
forthcoming we are also troubled by the
fact that the majority of conflicts not
only have been compounded by external
intervention but they have been
exacerbated by attempts by actors
stepping in to impose
one-sided solutions while at the same
time ignoring the views of local
residents tribal ethnic religious and
sectarian groups
it is evident that one of the bases for
the establishment of long-term stability
in the region is progress in the process
of middle east settlement with a
lynchpin
namely a fair solution to the
palestinian problem unfortunately
tensions on the west bank of the jordan
river and then the gaza strip continue
unabated and the problems persist with
upholding the ceasefire and problems
persist in the provision of humanitarian
assistance so to the palestinian
victims and reviving the peace process
against this backdrop there is ongoing
unilateral action which is brought with
dangerous consequences such actions
include expropriation and the
destruction of palestinian property the
construction of settlements including
plan construction plans in the occupied
syrian golan
and arbitrary arrests as well as
violations of the status of the holy
sites and violence at the same time we
note
the importance of bearing israel's
security interests in mind in this
connection we call for
an issue of unilateral action and
unilateral steps
international cooperation and concerted
measures should be accompanied by
progress in middle east settlement the
main objective in the period unfolding
in our view is the provision of urgent
humanitarian assistance to all those in
need in the gaza strip more than ever
before the work of unra is important as
a support to anwar by international
stakeholders at the same time we wish to
note that the entire gamut of final
status issues needs to be addressed
during direct negotiations between the
palestinians and israelis these
negotiations need to be launched at the
first opportunity without further delay
as a permanent member of the united
nations security council and as a
participant in the quartet of
international mediators the russian
federation assiduously strives to
achieve a settlement on the
international
basis namely united nations resolutions
the madrid principles the arab peace
initiatives these
stipulate
the creation of an independent sovereign
and contiguous palestinian state within
the 1967 borders with east jerusalem its
capital we call upon our partners
in the quartet the united nations eu and
the united states to step up cooperation
to that end on 14 october we held
another virtual meeting with the special
representatives we emphasized the
importance of convening ministerial
level meetings of the quartet
inter alia in the lead up to the 30th
anniversary of the madrid conference on
the middle east we also stand ready to
engage in dialogue with key regional
players and to involve them in the
efforts of the quartet we wish to note
the selection of a number of states in
the middle east region the fact that
these states have opted to normalize
relations with israel we believe that
such efforts will have a positive impact
on the situation in the region only if
at their focus
is finding a fair solution to the
palestinian problem on the
internationally recognized legal basis
as the recent outbreak of tensions
around the gaza strip has shown there is
no other way forward
the russian federation is actively
engaged with engaged with various
palestinian stakeholders to surmount the
international divide we are facilitating
the efforts of our egyptian friends to
that end we specifically welcome the
recently held palestinian jordanian
egyptian summit in cairo we cherish the
hope that this will be the first step
towards a fundamental shift in the
status quo which is at an impasse
thank you
i thank the representative of the
russian federation for his statement
and i'll give the floor to the
representative of vietnam
and thank you mr president and thanks
pastor coordinator douglas land for his
informative briefings also thanks mr
daniel levy and miss hanan ashrawi for
their insights
i welcome the participation of the
representatives of palestine and israel
to the meeting today with the president
we are concerned over the continued
violence in the occupied palestinian
treachery
since the announcement of the seas of
hostilities in may tension and violence
between the parties have unfortunately
not subsided in the west bank including
its jerusalem
in reality glasses continue to cause
rising numbers of palestinian casualties
settler-related violence remains a major
concern during the early harvest season
we are particularly troubled that
children have been for long exposed to
violence
as the occupying power israel
has an obligation to ensure the safety
and securities of the palestinian
population especially children
the israeli authorities must see the
excessive use of force against civilians
and carry out impartial and prompt
investigation into all violent attacks
the cultures of impunity must be ended
we also urge all party to exercise
restraint and refrain from any actions
and hydraulic
he told ricks that may feel tensions
with the president the seemingly endless
violence that we have in this only
underscore the importance of a just
lasting and comprehensive settlement
of this conflict as long as the
occupation the settlement activities and
the demolition of palestinian property
continues there will be no sustainable
peace
however the trends on the ground is not
increasing
we continue to be concerned by reports
that german projects are being advanced
in the west bank including jerusalem we
reiterate that all settlements are
illegal under international laws and
they undermine the prospects for
achieving a viable two-state solution
and in line with resolution 23
we call on the israeli authority to
permanently end all settlement
activities and the demolition of
palestinian property in the west bank
including its jerusalem
that would be an important step toward
building trust and returning to
negotiations
once again
we reiterate our strong support for the
two-state solution including the
establishment of the state of palestine
with israel message hospital
the states peacefully coexist alongside
with the state of israel which secured
an internationally recognized border on
the verdict of the
pre-1967 light and negotiated settlement
and in accordance with the international
law the u.n charter and the relevant un
resolution
especially security council resolution
to 334
mr president
we welcome the recent encouragement
between senior officers
engagement between
senior officer from the government of
israel and the palestinian authority
there is an important and positive step
to strengthen cooperation in the area of
security and economic policies we
encourage further direct engagement and
going on all going on both sides to work
together to facilitate the
reconstruction of gada and boost the
palestinian economy
concrete step towards the end when
contributes to creating an atmosphere of
trust between the party and paving the
pathway toward broad and significant
dialogues and negotiation
we want to combine efforts by
international actors to facilitate the
building of this momentum with the
president we know the recent step to
ease assessed restriction into and out
of the strip
how but all humanitarian and
reconstruction efforts should be further
facilitated since the situation regatta
remain volatile
we appreciate the work of umrah and un
agencies in ensuring the delivery of
critical aids to palestinians in gaza
however humanitarian staff from the u.n
and international non-governmental
organization must be able to enter and
exit together on a regular basis
crossing
should be open to commercial commercial
humanitarian goods and reconstruction
material and in the long term the
blockage of gada must be fully lifted
in this connection we urge the
international community to hit the
score for an increase of 6.1 million
including 43 additional posts for ira to
support education healthcare and general
assistance to palestinian refugees
before conclusions i would like to
reiterate vietnam's unwavering support
for the legislative struggles of
palestinian people and their inalienable
right i thank you mr president
i thank the representative of vietnam
for his statement
i shall now make a statement in my
capacity as the foreign affairs
principal secretary
for kenya
excellencies
ladies and gentlemen
since 1948
this council has addressed the situation
in the middle east
and the palestinian question on numerous
occasions
every month the council gets to hear of
developments and observations and
recommendations stemming from the
important work of the special
coordinators office
and various briefers engaged on this
issue
and i thank mr wienersland
dr ashirahi and mr levy for
their interventions this morning
i would also like to recognize the
presence of the distinguished
representatives of israel and palestine
in this debate
as the body entrusted with the primary
responsibility of maintenance of
international peace and security we need
to act
to ask rather
what else can we do to sustain
and sustainably answer
the palestinian question
our interest
as kenya
has and will always remain to support an
end
to this lasting threat to peace and the
security
in the middle east
peace and security in the middle east
has a damaging
domino effect
which reaches many parts of the world
including the sub-region and even our
own neighborhood
let no one believe even for one fleeting
moment
that owing to the character of the
debate today that kenya does not remain
gravely concerned with the situation in
the middle east
outside of israel and palestine
kenya
though distant from the middle east
has tragically seen kenyan blood and
lives lost
to terrorists inspired by the politics
and the
situation
in the middle east
this council has called for and ordered
ceasefires
the latest one being four months ago
following the 11 days of hostility
between israel and hamas
it has tabled resolution after
resolution with recommendations and
principles including 2334
to frame a negotiated peaceful
settlement for this protracted conflict
indeed kenya has called for the
reinforcement of unrwa as has many
member states here today the cessation
of israeli settlement activity in the
west bank and east jerusalem
and demolitions including those that
pose a
risk
to the actualization of the two-state
solution and undermine the territorial
contiguity
of a viable palestinian state based on
the 1969
67 lines rather
have highlighted the importance of
secure borders and safety and security
for both israeli as well as palestinians
protection of the status quo of
jerusalem and the important work of
unifil
a new ndof
in the contributing to the in
contributing to the stability of the
sub-region
and we have regularly taken note of the
progress made particularly when it comes
to cooperation between israel and
palestinian authorities
and regional media mediation efforts
kenya in particular has repeatedly
condemned terrorist attacks and acts
conducive to terrorists perpetuated to
terrorism rather perpetuated by hamas
palestinian islamic jihad and other
affiliated militant groups against
israeli civilians and civilian
infrastructure
we have condemned those who call for the
application of international
human rights and international law
but still violate the same among their
own communities
excellencies
as intractable as the conflict may seem
in the past
there have been political breakthroughs
that have come even
in the steepest of challenges
and as we face the largest of barriers
so what then is the missing link
to resolving this protracted situation
in a sustainable manner
i suggest to us that however much the
security council may have or may wish to
do
the answer lies in the end
in the hands and the minds of israeli
and palestinian people and palestinian
leadership and israeli leadership
we should no longer prescribe peace
but rather allow palestinians and
israelis to chart the cause for peace
and harmonious cognitive coexistence
through genuine and truly inclusive
dialogue that is rooted
in the communities
we are persuaded
that the leadership of both parties must
intentionally embrace
scale up and actualize mutual peace
by empowering those among them that are
working for peace
and it is this grassed root tear
that i wish to speak about
for the rest of my statement
at the formal peace talk stream
what we call official channels
there has been a tendency to frame and
discuss this conflict and peace process
around legal
and political frameworks that seem far
removed from the important elements
that israeli and palestinian communities
at the grassroots
who currently coexist side by side
considered to be important
and that they are grappling with on a
daily basis
the result of this tier one approach has
proved that solutions
or conclusions offered at this level
are geared primarily on the macro
political
and or economic issues
while the layered
socio-political theological tensions
and other dimensions of society continue
to bubble underneath
a few weeks ago
during the briefings of the
implementation of resolution 2334
one of the civil society young female
briefers reminded us that the conflict
we are dealing with today
is partly the result of the approach
taken 20 years ago
and still ongoing
that prioritizes
the official channels
of a diverse
grassroots
based organizations
and the channels that they themselves
create
these grassroots organizations
embody years of direct and boldly
grappling with social political and
theological concepts
whether related to muslims
jewish
or christians
to define interpret and contextualize
the historical and immediate political
experiences
and realities
of these people's daily lives
let us therefore hear more from them
and revisit
reframe and reassess this council's
efforts
in the same courageous vein
embodied by both israeli and palestinian
young
and grassroots leaders
who are daily coexisting
as i said and constructively building
inter-ethic and inter-cultural peace
who are calling for things
as they are
and are seeking accountability for those
things
where it is needed
we make these observations not to make
any false equivalences
but to urge for actual movement
away from the current
endless
conversation
that has seized this council
to rapid but nonetheless longer term
solutions
and tangible outcomes to this state to
this situation
i thank you for your attention
i now resume
my function as president of the council
there are no more names inscribed on the
speakers list
meeting is therefore adjourned
lady
you